all right we are now live and this is
going to be a rather controversial one I
imagine for these these doctors say
other philosophy pop-ups which are these
these sort of impromptu discussions that
that I have online with my viewers and
subscribers and other people who show up
so we're gonna be talking today about
all of the protests and the police
responses here in America particularly
here in the Midwest not just in in
Milwaukee where I'm you know
broadcasting from right now where we had
some significant protests ourselves in
the last couple days but you know in
other cities as well and I want to
discuss quite a bit of this from ethical
perspectives those of you who are
weighing in on this I've already had to
delete some people's comments because
like I say in the video description make
sure to keep it relevant make sure to
keep it civil we are discussing this
whole you know set of matters that are
catalyzed by the killing of George Floyd
in Minneapolis by Minneapolis police
officers in particular the one who's
been charged Eric Chavan and we're gonna
be talking about larger issues of
policing and how it can be done well and
and what's wrong with it and how it
bears heavily on some communities much
more than others I'll tell you right off
the bat I am NOT a sort of on one
extreme or the other kind of person you
know I have quite a few cops in my my
family who you know worked in different
aspects of policing and it really is the
truth that you know good cops do need to
start speaking up against bad cops and
what's going on and that there's far too
little of that I'm also not for police
abolition you know I think that's kind
of a utopian idea that's not
particularly helpful at this time so
what I'm going to
about largely comes from the middle and
and is coming also from thinking about
you know again the ethical perspectives
that's stepping back a little bit would
would help us to focus on rather than me
Jurek responses so you know a lot of
these questions about you know I'm sure
on and all that listen I'm not going to
do that in this pop up we're gonna be
talking about sort of nuts and bolts
stuff we're not going to be trying to
adjust things that I think don't have
much impact on the immediate situation
to you know what we have to talk about
here so let's let's talk about the
situation itself and I'll do kind of a
thumbnail sketch because we do have a
lot of foreign viewers and subscribers
who get onto these these things here in
the United States we do not have a
national policing sort of protocol or
system or anything like that it's very
very localized so each city has its own
police force which could be good or
could be bad you know the leadership
could be corrupt as it was here in
Milwaukee just recently you know when we
had our Sheriff David Clark in charge of
the Sheriff's Department who
subsequently went on to try to you know
glom onto the Trump administration via
Fox News host you know him the guy with
all the medals that he gave himself he
was in charge of the Sheriff's
Department which is in charge of County
policing here so you can have people
like that or and then the next
municipality over you might have
somebody who's a very conscientious
ethical police chief training varies
incredibly across the board for officers
there are some police departments that
are so at this point so rotten that they
probably need to be routed out from the
ground up and everyone fired and bring
in new people there are others who are
you know quite good so you know for a
lot of people don't don't quite get this
there is no single like policing system
here that does things that said you can
say that throughout our mayor
American cities where we do have quite a
lot of you know racial inequalities that
go back generations sometimes centuries
the brunt of of policing often does fall
quite heavily those who are
disadvantaged in different ways and race
is one of the ways in which that happens
here in Milwaukee we have one of the
most still segregated cities in the
United States so you can bet that that
is going to be a significant problem now
the issue itself people you know are
gonna want to talk about and there has
been a lot of discourse on Twitter and
on Facebook and another social media of
course in the news as well and an
opinion sources about George Floyd in
particular and about Derek trova in
particular but this is you might say
sort of a I said it was a catalyst
because it's a symbol of a much larger
problem you know the March is here in
Milwaukee they didn't just reference
George Floyd or you know with the I
can't breathe other incidents like the
one in New York City right they're
referencing people who've been killed
here in Milwaukee in the last ten years
and this is the case in cities all over
the place we can usually find some sort
of incident the marches here in
Milwaukee often begin at red arrow Park
where an officer killed a homeless man
back if I remember right in 2014 so
there's a lot of deep roots for these
conflicts going on and these are ethical
conflicts so there's a long-standing
problem of racism how should we look at
racism from ethical perspectives you
know there are people who want to try to
justify it by appeals to you know
evolutionary biology or things like that
it's it's very difficult to find any
ethics today who and this has not always
been the case by the way you know the
Intelligencia back in the 20s and 30s
here in the United States as well as in
Germany and other places kind of took
racism to be you know the way to under
stand things I think now in the present
we've made enough moral progress where
we can recognize that from just about
any ethical perspective you want to pick
if it's worth a damn racism is wrong
it's you know even if we think about in
terms of religious ethics you can
recognize it as as sinful as in some
respects disgusting no you know myself I
come from a family my adopted family who
are quite explicitly anti-racist
although struggling with their own
biases but you know I think about my own
father and getting in fights with people
in northern Wisconsin who are trying to
say that that what Hitler did was was ok
and thinking about growing up here in
this this area we have a long-standing
problem with racism in a number of
different ways and it's not simply a
matter of individual biases or
assumptions it can be systemic and I
think anybody who wants to try to deny
that there is systemic racism and quite
a few of our institutions which include
policing but also often include
education and medical matters all of
which by the way are the same
decentralized mass as policing is I I
think it has some sort of agenda to try
to deny evident realities or they've
either they've been under stone forever
and then those those are people who you
can reach and so there's an ethical
problem not only of engaging in racism
or you know furthering racist attitudes
but of denying it as well of pretending
that it doesn't exist and that it's not
affecting things the police responses to
the protests you know it's interesting
I've been engaging in some discussion on
on Twitter and on Facebook over the last
couple days as I've been posting things
by the way also losing followers and and
likers on those I'm sure I'll eventually
get some other people back and I will
say this is a side note to if talking
about these things is enough to make
somebody say oh I don't I don't want
that in my stream screw them I'm
to see him go you know we're doing
carrying out sort of a winnowing process
here and I think that this really is a
catalyzing set of events that are going
to be quite important here sirens now
again in the city there was probably
something going on even today so going
on with this talking about the the
protests I think it's it's perfectly
legitimate to protest on mass about this
sort of extrajudicial killing which is
what it is and about the the sort of
mentality and the systems and the
justifications and excuses that allow
this to become commonplace you know it
makes sense that people would would
march here in Milwaukee we had you know
marchers going throughout the city quite
a long route that actually took them
only two blocks away from from our
apartment where we were watching from
from the windows and then we watched the
police come through the police responses
in many cases have been not only in in
how they actually attacked people but in
just the lining up and coordinating
people off have been excessive you know
we have highly militarized police forces
here in the United States and that's
that's a topic we'll get into in a
moment I think that should definitely
not be the case and that that rot has
been allowed to continue for years I had
a good friend of mine Caleb who's a
veteran as well on to talk about this
years ago when we are seeing this as a
big problem but the police responses to
the protesters in many cases attempting
to provoke clearly I mean this is it's
amazing what we can see because there's
so many people recording on their phones
the stuff that otherwise would have been
poo pooed and said oh no no no the
police never do that sort of thing this
is the time when citizens military and
veterans and fellow law enforcement
officers ought to be engaging in
clear unequivocal condemnation of police
misconduct that's that's an ethical
imperative I believe and those who don't
want to do it again you know they
probably need to look into their own
motivations for why they would like to
say things like oh you know it's only
the protesters acting violent towards
the police now there there are some
cases where people stirred stuff up
right and I'm not gonna like say that
it's all outside agitators there are
many people who are quite angry which
we'll talk about in a moment as well and
some of the anger is a you could say
misplaced and poorly managed anger and
there are some people who are you know
career criminals participating in
protests but that's not the majority of
them and for the police to line up and
treat people their own fellow citizens
their own residents of their own City
except the police of course who don't
live in the city because they've been
allowed by police unions which are
essentially just organizations to cover
up police misconduct they've ceased it
to be any sort of labor union long ago
that sort of stuff you know there's
there's no justification for it instead
we could look at models of policing
where that didn't happen where things
didn't get out of hand and say well it
doesn't have to go this way the police
are used to doing things like that and
many of them as individuals quite
clearly you can see them looking forward
to going and cracking some heads or
spraying some people's faces but that
doesn't justify it at all as a matter of
fact I'm getting a little bit off topic
here but one of the things I'd like to
assert from an ethical perspective
police officers should be held to higher
standards than ordinary people there
should be zero excuse and zero tolerance
for abuses of power when you allow that
you know the few bad apples idea then
they do corrupt the rest so many people
keep forgetting about this bad apples
metaphor that you know when you do have
a barrel of apples and there is one or
two bad apples it all goes to crap
because you didn't pull them out
we need to have much better screening
for police officers we need to have
oversight we need retraining we need to
make policing into a profession where
it's not attracting people who look at
you know TV shows and and say oh I I
want to go and beat some people up I
want to have arbitrary power over other
people
we need to screen those psychos out and
bring in people who can actually deal
with other quite often upset human
beings as human beings you know I
remember when I was teaching in Indiana
State Prison and I interact with with
CEOs all the time that was my first
full-time teaching job teaching
full-time behind the walls of a
maximum-security prison where they
carried out executions you could tell
which officers were the ones who were in
it for good reasons because of the way
they treated people other staff inmates
those of us who came in to teach and you
could tell the ones that were the rotten
apples who should have been pulled out
of there and gotten rid of and put into
some other some other job or you know
whatever else is going to happen to them
and you can say the same about about
police forces I would say as well you
know what we need is a drastic overhaul
of things the other thing that I do want
to say is is about anger so you know
there is a lot of anger about police
brutality there's there's quite a bit in
the the communities that have been
negatively affected by this for a long
time there's quite a bit of it on the
part of other communities that look at
this and they say this is injustice that
cries out to heaven or whatever other
metaphor you want to say you know and
then there's plenty of anger on the part
of the people who are saying oh you know
they shouldn't riot they should be you
know peaceful all the time and you know
they'll do a couple MLK quotes and stuff
like that there's a lot of anger out
there in general right and then there's
angry cops I mean being a cop by its
very nature places one at a greater risk
for mismanagement of anger and puts
weapons into your hands that
the deadly force against people and you
know doesn't necessarily depending on
the department you know doesn't prepare
people well for for dealing with that I
think what we need to recognize here is
that that there is a lot of displaced
and mismanaged anger and that should be
condemned you know that shouldn't be an
excuse for engaging in something and
then there's also legitimate anger and
you know some people said well why don't
they direct it just at the you know the
governmental processes well they have
but I mean it's not as if the
discussions about police brutality and
how it you know impinges on the
african-american community particularly
on young men haven't been going on for
years and years and years here in
Milwaukee here in so many other places
that you know the last thing that I'll
say and I'll start answering questions
is that you know I'm not saying I'm
those of you who are saying we need to
abolish the police I don't agree with
that I think we need to drastically
defund the police I think we need to
reduce police budgets Minneapolis
there's this great Forbes article that
came out a while ago that that targeted
Minneapolis in particular as one of the
places that blows a lot of their budget
on policing this is what allows cops to
have all this riot gear and you know CS
gas and you know all this other stuff
that and of course the corrupt police
unions that we need to get rid of as
well I'm not saying that police officers
need to be without any sort of legal
representation or something like that
but the unions that exist they need to
go because they are not labor unions
they are just essentially criminal
organizations to cover up police
misconduct we could spend a lot less on
policing and get way better results than
we are by holding you know officers to
higher standards by reducing the size of
police forces by telling them you don't
get to you know roll out in gear that
our military doesn't actually need to
have in order to handle things well
alright so I'm going to
there's a lot of comments here and we'll
address that so all Viking says troops
need to be brought in I agree and I
think that we ought to bring in the
military and have the military in
between the police and the protesters
and I think the military ought to be
directed against the police departments
that are engaging in violent behavior on
their own part and I think that you know
by the way we're talking about this this
morning you know other than the ones who
actually went and served in Afghanistan
or Iraq the National Guard are not taken
seriously by actual veterans and and
people in the real military you know
they're often what we call weekend
warriors they're the people who you know
have a civilian job and then they go
play soldier and then you know they're
they're happy to get called out so that
they can screw around with in our cities
I'm actually cool with bringing in the
military because the military should be
used to keep the police in line now
that's probably not what you had in mind
all right Lenny penny how would it
Nietzschean act in these times who cares
you know that's that's not relevant here
mother says peace and love from Portland
yeah that's that's good another about
Camus is the rebel okay could compose
the rebel be relevant for the current
riots yeah in a certain way I mean if
you read cow Moos work he was always in
a difficult position where he said that
that you know by the way you know in in
in mythos if it's Sisyphus its suicide
that's the philosophical problem by the
time of the rebel its murder its murder
that is the problem that's that's
produced by the absurd and it's
something that we need to take account
of and we need to think about how we
ourselves whether we like it or not
are caught up in systems that do engage
in murder and we could say not just
murder but oppression and exploitation
of our fellow human beings
now Camus was not a utopia he realized
how difficult the situation was
in so many cases and he said well we
still have to try to do something and we
have to stand up for decency and a lot
of people gave him a very hard time
because during the you know very brutal
Algerian war he refused to take a side
as being the good guys that he was going
to back all the way
so actually cow Moo is kind of relevant
here stupid comment by where's my my
eyebrow nice facial hair who gives a
[ __ ]
diabolus ex machina doesn't pragmatism
provide many of our solutions of this
for both sides
I mean pragmatic philosophy could play a
role in this but you know don't think
that any sort of philosophical system is
going to come in and fix this sort of
thing all I can do is provide us
insights you know and pragmatism can
mean a million different things to a
million different people so I wouldn't
put too much on that alright Jacob the
violence vandalism and looting don't
seem like moral means am I missing
something why aren't more public
officials urging nonviolent means plenty
of public officials are urging
nonviolent means they've been urging it
forever sometimes and by the way we can
easily say yes there's problems with
violence with looting the violence
however is coming mostly from the cops
quite frankly the looting is happening
by protesters but many of them aren't
actually protesters like great great
example here in Milwaukee the looting
didn't happen until well after curfew
right you know the the marches were
perfectly fine there weren't a lot of
problems with that thank God we don't
have that that idiot sheriff Clark here
in town anymore because if if we did
then his sheriffs would have been using
brutal force against protesters
guaranteed but we can say that we don't
condone and we actually condemn the
looting and violence and we can also say
it's a natural response to people who
are oppressed and are ignored and then
see one of their fellow human beings
treated in the same way that they're
becoming accustomed to see by police
somewhere else those are not
incompatible
and that's important to keep in mind for
everybody who's boggled by the the
violence of the protesters if you're not
as concerned about the police's violence
and not just in in suppressing the
protests but day to day to day you lose
any moral credibility all right
iemon what is my wife and partner think
about these riots she's pretty much on
the same line
you know same same page as me I think
we've talked about it quite a bit
Nicholas thank you from Southern
California we need philosophers to guide
us through this again
I don't think philosophy is gonna
provide us that much guidance per se but
it can add some some useful voices in
there and maybe confirm some things here
and there all right who is a good
question from the undiscovered self
aren't good cops that do not talk about
bad cops really in fact bad cops by dint
of collusion by silence and the answer
is yes you know like I said when you
have a barrel full of apples and you
want to claim that there's just a few
bad apples in it you're not gonna have
just a few bad apples after a couple
weeks so if you have a police department
where people are looking away from the
evils I want you to call them evils that
that bad cops are imposing on the people
who they're supposed to be protecting
and serving the people who they're paid
and trained to take care of when the
police are actually the Predators and
you don't say anything about it yes you
become a bad cop don't become as bad a
cop right but you do become a bad cop
and inevitably these things have the
corrupting effect if you see your fellow
officers engaging in injustice the same
thing goes by the way for prisons and
and correctional officers and getting
away with it
eventually you're gonna start you know
inevitably being tempted to do the same
sort of things yourself and say you know
it's it's very difficult to maintain any
sort of moral perspective this is why
it's so important that we have oversight
and leadership
of police departments that doesn't
accept those sorts of you know well it's
what we have to do kinds of excuses or
it's always been done this way you know
or were you know cracking down but only
on the criminal sorts of excuses there
needs to be real examination and
analysis of what happens and and you
know fortunately we have these mobile
devices that are allowing us as citizens
to broadcast what police are doing
because think about what it would be
like if we didn't have cell phones and
and people weren't filming the police if
it's this bad right now what would it be
like if there was no checking up on them
all right let's see Jacob does some of
this pertain to Nietzsche beyond good
and evil and optics I don't know how it
would pertain to beyond good and evil in
particular I mean optics is an
interesting term to use here
I think we've lived in a time when
there's been maybe too much attention
given to optics and not enough attention
given to how things actually are
happening you know too much attention to
spinning messages and not enough to
basic decency and it's violations by the
very people who are supposed to be
protecting those being predatory on the
you know the populations who are
essentially kept therein in ghettos
again here in Milwaukee very segregated
community you wouldn't guess it from
where we live in the downtown because
this is a very diverse area and there's
another places like neighborhoods like
River West where it's quite diverse but
then there's other places where it's all
like predominantly african-american are
predominantly Hispanic even there's even
like a little Asian area or
predominantly white if you look at the
Greater Milwaukee area and that's a
problem you know some of the poorest ZIP
codes in the United States are here in
Milwaukee and it's not you know it's
it's it's
it's not a just sort of surprise who
knew that this is the case we have been
talking about this for years and years
and years this is one of the most
intractable problems that we have here
in this great city of Milwaukee
the fact of these these vast racial
disparities that affect not just
policing but who gets medical care the
kovat crisis has been bearing heavily on
that where businesses get located
education all of these things are part
of them all right Stacy Washington
thanks for what you do I have a
philosophy ba from Utah okay that's good
John Doe Thank You Gregg now denounce
the fascist police states that as the
USA there's an ax fascist police state
that is the USA I mean there is an AAA
system in place when it comes to
policing this is something I was saying
earlier we have every single County has
its own Sheriff's right and that's its
own entity they're not accountable to
the federal government they're not
accountable to the state government down
in in the South sometimes the sheriff's
are the most powerful policing entity
there is up here it's a little bit more
restricted then each municipality has
its own police force then we have our
state troopers that's a whole different
ballgame you know then what do we have
in terms of federal police state well we
have our different agencies right like
Border Patrol which is by itself a
corrupt mess of racists as we know right
or you know all the federal marshals or
things like that but those are just a
small amount compared to all the local
policing so you know why would I
denounce the police state that is the
USA that's ridiculous all right Stacey
Washington writes teachers include
visiting professor I have no idea what
this is about here so I'm gonna skip it
all right Nicholas Gomez if police throw
tear gas into a crowd of people is it
unethical to throw the tear gas back at
the police I don't know the answer does
authority make some degree of violence
permissible no as a matter of
fact authority means that they have to
be more circumspect about their use of
violence with you know more
responsibility and more privileges come
a greater you know obligation to first
of all follow the law and to be
proportionate in the use of violence is
there is there a problem with throwing
tear gas back at the the police no the
police shouldn't be using tear gas at
this point anyway you know I think that
in in a lot of cases police seem to want
to ratchet up the violence so that they
can use the you know overwhelming force
that they typically have at any given
point because that's the way they like
to solve problems but they are
generating more and more and more
problems by doing that I mean we are at
the point now with with police in
different places again you know here in
Milwaukee fortunately we we seem to have
decent leadership of the police at this
point in time but you know police are
indiscriminately firing rubber bullets
at people they're attacking medical
personnel they're attacking reporters
the press they're way out of control in
in quite a few places there is nothing
wrong with throwing tear gas back at
them I mean it's not gonna be that
effective because they've got gas masks
right that's why they're using tear gas
all right the police officers have too
much ego that they face civilians one on
one the problem starts there well that
that is a problem and now by the way I'm
gonna say I've known a lot of good
police officers over the years as I
mentioned I have police officers in my
family and I and I've known you know
quite a few who are in ethical
quandaries about what happens with with
their forces but there is a tendency and
and you know this is why we need
screening of police officers so we can
get the the people who are in it for the
wrong reasons out of policing and get
keep them out for good we also need to
have like a national database where if
somebody gets fired from a police
department for something they can't get
hired at other departments because this
is another big problem that we have
because of our decentralized non system
of policing
so yeah there there's a lot of like
interpersonal dynamics that that you
know are result of you can call it ego I
would call it being vicious this morally
alright meek and pure I think there's
real open there's real oppression
towards african-americans in America and
George Floyd does deserve justice but I
disagree with the burning of businesses
and lootings violence doesn't lead to
peace well it allows you to you know
make the case yeah it's it's better if
instead of local businesses being burned
that it's a police headquarters as we as
we saw or you know the courthouse or I'm
all for that you know the places that
are defacing the Confederate statues
that are there those things should have
been gone a long time ago only haven't
because of racism but if if that's what
it takes I mean here's here's the thing
to keep in mind for all the people who
want to bring up MLK and nonviolent
protests and all that read a letter from
a Birmingham jail what is the thing that
Martin Luther King says he says well you
know gives all these these these
arguments against the white liberals and
against you know people are like oh you
need to take more time and all that he
says no no the time is now for changing
things and either you deal with people
like me who are willing to let our
skulls be cracked and police dogs sicked
on us because all of you are such
scumbags that want to use that sort of
force and either you deal with us or you
can deal with the people who are gonna
engage in all sorts of other things you
know the people who are going to be
violent make a choice because it's going
to be one or the other and I think we
can say a similar thing today yeah it's
it's it's not good that businesses are
being burned down or looted or anything
like that
that said walgreens has insurance and so
does target and it's a it's a property
crime it's not actually beating
somebody's skull in with a baton or
shooting a rubber bullet into their eye
or things like that
which are
our actions against persons which are
being done much more by the police than
by the protesters so I think we need to
keep things you know proportionate in
mind that's that's that's the one thing
that I think philosophy might be able to
contribute is relentlessly drilling in
distinctions destroying property is not
the same thing as destroying a person
you know that's that's a key distinction
that with that somebody has to keep in
mind if they're going to engage in moral
ethical reasoning about this all right
John Doe says we need to abolish the
police great tell me how that's going to
happen and what's going to replace them
that isn't going to look like the police
I mean it's nice to to have that sort of
ideology I think that people who have
that sort of ideologies you know my
friend ear fun commented in a Facebook
thing about somebody who is an
abolitionist and said well we do need
these people because they you know they
they they push something forward in that
that's good but how's that can happen I
mean I think we need to be very
realistic in and the changes that were
demanding I think that we want to we
want to push for getting rid of police
unions that's that's doable that's gonna
be very very very hard but that's doable
getting rid of all police altogether I
don't see how that's going to happen so
all right Bruce asks what about
economics now do I think that the
economy is going back to where it was
and then that can be an exacerbation
factor I mean the Cota we could call it
the Cova displacements have fallen more
heavily on minority communities they
sure as hell haven't affected police
budgets the economy was bad for a lot of
people before we got into this the
economy's never closed you know we just
actually had an order come in today from
Costco there's a shopper who went and
and purchased things for us you know we
do that because you know we're not we're
not going ourselves to the store because
I have somebody who's high risk in my
family so the economy never really
closed there's parts of the economy that
are doing much worse and parts that are
doing better and we do have a lot of
problems
like people not being able to pay rent
or being out of work and having their
unemployment terminated because of
political machinations so you know are
we ever gonna see like a return to
previous levels think about the previous
2008 about 2007 to 2010 or 11 economic
crisis right by 2012 we saw a lot of
things getting back to normal but the
new normal
wasn't good for a lot of people so I
think that's something we need to focus
on as well but that's a good question
all right more people talking about who
their teachers were Olivia says I think
you're missing a key part of this career
criminals thing namely that people go
into the informal economy because of
white supremacy and the economic
privation it brings yeah and I'm not
talking about career criminals in that
sense so let me specify when I when I
talk about career criminals and I'm
talking about people looting things I'm
not talking about people who are
engaging in non documented economic
trends you know transactions I'm talking
about the kind of people who I taught
when I was in maximum-security prison
teaching you know the kind of people who
are out there and are like well there's
disorder I'm gonna take advantage of
this you know and and there is that
element and you're always going to have
that but that doesn't define a protest
right that's gonna be a pretty small
number of people and we also ought to
mention there's right-wingers out there
stirring crap up as well right and and
yeah so there's it's it's not as if most
of the protesters are in any way
engaging in violence as a matter of fact
some of been raining people in as well
sunflower says they're in Iran they've
observed it in part of this kind of
chaos in results of poor action or
dictator politicians yeah you're on is a
mess has been for a mess for quite a
long time that's
something that would be kind of good for
us to keep in mind particularly going
back to that comment about the you know
police state that is America things
could be much much much worse you know
and in some times if we if we think
about the racial oppression and
exploitation that's taken place in our
past directed at African Americans but
also direct that you know we can say at
Native Americans and Hispanics and you
know really across the board it's been
much worse right
but this is still bad this is still we
could say it's still at a level that's
morally unacceptable
when it comes to policing and racial
inequalities and disparities and what's
being done to to address them and what
gives people a seat at the table so
alright meek and pure says 400 years of
racial injustice that was ignored for
too long caught up to us and a lack of
love on the side of people burning and
looting businesses yeah I mean that's
all rather abstract stuff I think the
the offenses that people are worried
about or more like what's happened in
the last five years that I'm the last
400 but you know you can have that as a
backburner kind of kind of issue as well
[ __ ] says burned down the city's tear
down the Parthenon again not a it's
about as useless as a response as the
let's justify the police or the let's
abolish the police these these sort of
total sit you know solutions aren't
really solutions for us we need to have
realistic we can do something about this
in the present kind of things that we
can address where we can do what what
you know we talked about as consistent
pressure relentlessly a prep applied you
know meek and pure society doesn't
thrive without laws and order yeah that
that's true and the law is an order need
to actually themselves be lawful and
orderly not falling on some people more
than on others without some good
reason and not you know perpetuating
systemic injustice otherwise the law is
an order cease being laws I mean this is
recognized early as early on as Cicero
and st. Augustine that legal systems
that are not preserving justice ceased
to be legal there's some sort of measure
some sort of standard that we have this
this is something that runs throughout
thought all the way by the way from
Aristotle to Martin Luther King of
talking about there being a superior law
that judges the laws and the enforcement
of the law that we have in place that's
what allows us to be moral beings not
just having laws and not just having
order because your order could be an
oppressive order you know and exploit it
to order all right I just jumped a bit
so a lot of comments here let's skip
back up to where we were and I'm gonna
try to address these fairly quickly so I
can catch up a bit rather than going
into here we go by anger and says build
up the cities yeah I would love to see
that a lot more I would love to see a
lot more constructive solutions to
things that's not a sexy and not not as
attention-getting and often draws a lot
more energy from people you know but
it's what we what we ought to do alright
Jake Lloyd says it's a shame about your
followers thanks for making a principled
stand on this issue yeah I mean I've
lost some over the years for for talking
about the current corrupt Republican
administration and what's going on here
in Wisconsin but that's okay you're
always going to shed some Gabrielle
Souza big civil marches are much better
to bring attention to the cause yeah and
we're having big civil marches I mean
it's not as if we only have violent
protests we're also we're having violent
protests at times and clashes with the
police and we have like demonstrations
and marches going on all over the place
as well all right
here is 1916 Rev do I believe using Hana
Ren's formulation that the violence
being used by the police is undermining
their power that's a good question
is it undermining their power yes it is
undermining their power because
legitimacy is part of power and when the
police are genuinely perceived across
the board is illegitimate they're going
to have less and less compliance and
they're gonna have to use more more
brutal tactics and that is going to lead
to more and more problems by the way if
you want to talk about economic issues
you want to have a recovery we're gonna
have to have a recovery by people being
free to do things if we have you know
lots and lots of curfews and clamp downs
and stuff like that because of bad
policing and bad bad leadership we are
we're gonna have even more of a problem
John Reeves says the police killed a man
let's have the police investigate that
question mark this is a problem having
the police and having that particular
prosecutor who who knows how many deals
he's cut with with less evidence than
you know what he's looking at there for
all sorts of criminals to try to coerce
them into into plea bargains yeah we
probably need external oversight of some
sort unfortunately the DOJ right now
who's running it right so we're not
going to get any help from that angle
because there are gonna be very Pro
police almost in a knee-jerk way but we
do need something mother says a rent
referencing the banality of evil went
down this cul-de-sac with finding
otherwise ordinary men do horrible
things for Penant for brevity I will say
penalties should be severe for cops
breaking the law yeah now the cops that
are doing this sort of stuff are not
ordinary men doing bad things there are
people who chose to become part of a
police force and many of them I mean you
can watch some of these videos where you
can see them like you know all
adrenaline-junkie DUP ready to go out
and crack some heads I know what that's
like because I you know when I was doing
martial arts you'd see people like that
you know and you know the plenty of
other circumstances as well so
it's it's not just oh well you know if
the ad system people can do bad things
without realizing it no some of these
people want to go out there and do do
bad stuff John Doe how does Marx tie in
to this I mean not in any immediate way
although I would say that one thing that
Marx and angles do point out in the
Communist Manifesto is that there is a
particular class of society that is
always willing to be like lined up with
the the oppressors all right
Percy says thank you for your work thank
you very much as well I can't read these
symbols but it says in fact we ordinary
people just want have a better life and
better family for protest we can't make
our life better
we just want work and health I think
that's I think that's the case I don't
think that most people who are engaging
in the protests are you know what we
could call like professional activists
who are like oh this is amazing now
we've got a chance to go out and do this
there's always going to be some right
but a lot of them are just people are so
fed up with how things have been going
[ __ ] says okay you're all sorts of
nonsense about ASE so I'm going to get
rid of that keep it relevant and keep it
accurate
so Emmerich says you're militarizing
police great idea nice speech way to put
more oil on the fire platitudes
everywhere in this vid oh cool get rid
of that one as well and alright meek and
pure injustice is real and should be
called out but we should love each other
at the same time that's that's a very
good point and it is possible to be
loving and to resist evil at the same
time and to call it by its name as a
matter of fact it's not as if there's an
immediate cause and effect but making
the other person who's engaging in
wrongful behavior realize that it's
wrongful behavior
is a good act of of itself all right I'm
gonna skip over the sterner one ok so
students to Bailey Billy says here in
Flint we had a very peaceful march where
the police marched with the protesters
please look up the story for more
details than I can get here I posted
that on Twitter and I posted that on
Facebook as a good example of a
different model of policing it was the
sheriff the County Sheriff who along
with his deputies marched and then gave
a address to the people and there wasn't
violence and that is something possible
to do so you know the people who are
like oh well you've got a clampdown
gotta have law and order well there's
different ways of doing that one is to
actually deal with oppressed human
beings as human beings all right Jorge
says here in Spain we also have problems
with police force what should we do with
this structure that affects all
countries so I mean in Spain you have a
more centralized police force than we do
here in the United States and that means
that in some respects you have better
prospects for actually doing something
about it I think then I mean here we
it's like whack-a-mole right you get an
officer who is a terrible person fired
in one place and they go a couple
municipalities down and they get a job
again at another place and then they
start doing the same stuff right or they
go and become a correctional officer
I think countries that that do have a
more unified approach to it like Spain
or France even Britain have a much you
know more easier way to go than we do
all right
Watergate 2.0 the police should be
trained to handle situations better
similar to how people are trained in the
military yeah I mean now the military
isn't our way the training that we get
there isn't always great either but it's
certainly way better than what happens
in a lot of policing and there has to be
continual retraining to that's that's a
key thing I think you can't just say
okay we're gonna
you know I was talking with another
person about this on Facebook these like
implicit bias workshops that you got to
sit in for four hours
those don't do a thing you know all
those do is take something off on a
compliance thing so they can say legally
well we actually have addressed this a
lot of times the people involved in
those don't take them seriously how do I
know this because it's not just cops who
get that it's also us educators and it's
other professions that get these
essentially compliance training things
we need something that goes a lot deeper
that gets its hooks into people and that
gets buy-in from people and that's not
going to be done with the stuff that we
we currently require of them and it's
gonna have to be continually renewed
leadership is gonna have to care about
it as well all right John Plato
descendant of democracy would eventually
descend into a tyranny win this be a
reflection of the current status in
America I don't think you can map what's
happening in Plato's Republic book eight
easily on to what happens at a giant
nation-state which is much more complex
so no I would not agree with that
zoun knows does cultural integration
work too burr on a topic not sure it has
anything to do with with this all right
a little bit of off-track stuff here I'm
gonna get ah here's a great question
Abbe OMA do you think there's a fair
parallel between Just War theory and
unspoken spoken expectations about a
kind of just Civil War disorder theory
yes and good ethical training for police
that actually encompasses moral theory
will include discussions of Just War
theory because it has to do with the use
of force you can you can analogize from
that and one we're talking about Just
War Theory we're talking about the stuff
that goes all the way back again to
Cicero Augustine Aquinas all of this
reflection on that many of those
principles apply just as well to
policing it's a matter of actually
getting that out there that is quite
difficult all right
Randy's like
unions are largely corrupt I've seen
that in the trades that's a whole other
discussion labor unions yeah there's
lots of problems with them including the
fact that it's it's often there they're
not working for the common person the
way they may have done way way in the
past unions are often kind of their own
little elite clique I know this in part
because give you a prime example my
uncle right who had at this point in
time is a union iron worker in the past
he was drywaller and they would have
these these you know Carpenters Union
people come down and to his jobs when he
was non-union and say you need to put
three guys of ours onto the job and he'd
be like you gonna put any of our guys
onto your jobs and they he'll know you
know they were demanding and not giving
anything for the ordinary person iron
workers it took him actually having his
son being the iron workers and giving
him a referral to get in there and then
get all the great free education and
jobs and stuff like that yeah
there's a whole conversation to be had
about the labor union movement police
unions are a whole different thing
police unions are not labor unions they
are their own animal and I think they
need to be abolished
I'm not saying police need to be
abolished police unions do so alright
Diabolus ex machina you've obviously
pointed to the problem militarism
in police and your opinion is it more
helpful or useful to see this as a
racial issue when does it come a problem
so I don't think the militarism the
militarization let me say of police is a
particularly racialized issue I think
that it has to do with the fact that the
Bush administration made all this
military equipment readily available for
police organizations and many of them
took advantage of it and they should
have never been afforded that that
opportunity there is you know unless
we're like dealing with like serious
criminal organizations like you know
hardcore gangs and stuff like that
there's no reason why police should have
military-grade
weaponry out on the street they
shouldn't have armored cars and you know
things along those lines and you know
there there's there's other things going
on as well some people have been posting
videos of the police for example going
to places where the protesters have
gathered jugs of milk and like pouring
all that stuff out what are they doing
there they're trying to destroy supply
lines for those who engage in protests
now what's going on there there's a
mentality of us versus them and the
people being the enemy and that's
militarism that's that's not proper
policing so alright there's a thing I'm
sure president Trump will manage things
well on the annual bring us to a
brighter future yeah I don't think so
that's that's that's such nonsense I
mean anybody who at this point thinks
that Trump cares at all about Americans
or indeed even about people in his
administration haven't haven't been
paying attention new card doesn't the
amount of guns in the US make police
brutality inevitable I don't think so
what you know what's what's keeping the
number of gun size actually the
Republican NRA coalition and that tends
to favor the cops a lot of there's a lot
of overlap between those people you know
you don't see the right to bear arms
being exercised primarily by
african-americans do you you know I mean
you can say well what about illegal guns
and the cops have to be armed okay sure
but that doesn't have anything to do
with protests and marches and stuff like
that and now they're dealing with that
that's ordinary policing all right so
all right let's go on Piku whelps rich
this durkheim's concept of protester
looting as an expression of untouched
social needs provide insight is the
function of this situation yeah but in a
trivial way I mean I think that's one of
those things where it's become basically
part of the understanding whether we've
read Durkheim or not of how these things
work so yeah
Robert Kipps have you seen the video of
military-looking police walked on
residential neighborhoods in Minneapolis
and shoot projectiles at people in their
front porch to force them inside their
own homes yes I have of course and if I
if I remember right those are not police
those are actually National Guard but
they may they may be police and they may
as well you know be police all right
that's a vast Onix as as finances to be
able to free the marginalize through
revolution violence this is necessary
our protesters entitled the use of
violence considering the system at
systemic oppression they are under so
entitled
meaning morally justified I would say in
some cases yes in some cases no I think
as soon as the police start using
violence on protesters on mosques that
they didn't you know anything goes then
you know if they want to heavily armed
start throwing tear gas at people then
too bad for the police you know are is
it sort of a general principle that well
if you're oppressed you can use violence
I don't think so if we do that then
everybody uses violence right and we
don't have a society for very long Jake
Lloyd suggests it what if police
officers had to be elected by the
community they police I think we'd be
better off yeah that would be quite
interesting or let's expand that because
I think that's actually a great you know
kernel of an idea what if police
officers had to be accountable and say
monthly meetings whether their actions
were reviewed by community members by
people who today police what if police
officers were indeed required to live in
the communities that they police you
know what if police officers were
required to send their children to
school in the communities that they
police and we could go on and on and on
right you could say well then they
become like held hostage I guess or
maybe they'll be a lot more accountable
and actual
like see other people as members of
their community all right Austin Noonan
it seems the Polly people have no power
anymore police are getting away with
anything they want what schools of
philosophy offers a solution besides
stoicism I don't think that stoicism per
se offers a solution I mean the solution
that stoicism would offer is get
involved in organization against the
police
it would not be Oh withdraw yourself
from stuff that's and I notice you use
the lowercase s stoicism that's not
actual stoicism stoicism was about you
know the cardinal virtues wisdom courage
temperance and what's the other one
justice if you look at Cicero and you
look at the actual Stoics and you see
the fact that some of the ones who we
don't have writings from got in trouble
with the government for protesting
against the government and holding them
to standards you know you would probably
not be inclined as view stoicism is just
a withdrawal from things but saying oh
we have to be involved with things I
think we can use other you know
Aristotle talks about the use of
violence and force you criticize the
Spartans for being all about fighting
and victory and losing sight of
everything else that's important in life
you know Aristotle by the way even
discusses in the politics that need to
have some sort of carceral institution
within the city and it gives some
guidelines for it but going back to your
other point it seems that people who
have no power anymore yeah the police
have been given far too much power I
think there's a lot of things that are
now considered crimes that probably
should be taken off the books you know
we're in a situation where if you like
have a police dog coming after you and
you defend yourself against it you're
considered to have attacked a police
officer but police officers can come in
and shoot your dog or if you you know if
you do anything it can be considered
resisting arrest a lot of those things
need to go you know and it's gonna be
very difficult for that to happen
because prosecutors love that stuff
gives them leverage all over people to
charge them for crimes and we do have an
incentivized system where prosecutors
are often rewarded the
more people they put behind bars you
know all right let's go on meek and pure
police need to build a better
relationship with the community yeah
exactly that that does need to happen
run Henderson we need community control
of police they should be drawn from the
communities they will police too many
officers don't live in and have a vested
interest in its well-being I think
that's completely correct all right Luke
Appleberry police shouldn't be elected
can you imagine a criminal voting in a
cop how that relationship work out and
that's not a real objection I mean so so
what you know what's the proportion of
criminals within the general populace so
you're gonna say that the general
populace shouldn't have a say in and who
is policing them because criminals exist
in there I mean some of those criminals
are cops by the way right all right
let's let's go on a lot of back and
forth mm-hmm says how can we reduce the
crime rates in the first place whether
these incidents don't happen punishment
reduce crime rates or education the only
way to reduce crime rates there is no
simple one key solution to reducing
crime rates crime rates have been going
down I mean they have been going down
historically for quite a while with most
types of crimes we often see a
disjunction between you know spending on
police and crime rates here's a good
observation biiian pro Finnell a lot of
pain and many many problems today yeah
that's something that we need to keep in
mind we're and when we're discussing
this we're not discussing merely
abstract issues that we can feel
emotional about we're talking about real
human people that get there you know get
hit by a rubber bullet or get
tear-gassed or you know suddenly are in
fear is they see a phalanx of cops
coming at them and have no idea what
they're gonna be doing and then hear
other sirens coming from behind them we
are dealing with P
who get you know searched for reasons
that that are often just about
terrorizing and keeping people in check
rather than actual policing there's a
lot of pain out there
and a lot of the anger comes from the
pain not just the pain existing the pain
not being acknowledged the pain being
told well that's your problem because
you shouldn't have resisted arrest or
you shouldn't have you know you have to
be respectful there's a lot of fear as
well especially among not just
african-american men but their families
about what can happen to them we live in
an unjust society when it comes to when
it comes to racism profiling and
policing and all of these other things
so yeah my wife Andy sent me a text that
some people think my CIA shirt is from
the Central Intelligence Agency I mean
all of you should know better than that
Culinary Institute of America right you
know anything about me you know that I
have a long-standing connection with
them so yeah glad to put that to rest
all right let me let me go down and see
what else we have so here's a comment
that I think is completely wrong headed
doctor you know now many people don't
care about this incident at all they
just want to make the whole kind of
turbulent they have bad ideas we
shouldn't go on protesting like that
that is exactly the wrong headed sort of
idea that that you should probably
reconsider and I know if you've posted a
lot of things in here about how great
Trump is and wonderful blah blah blah
blah blah if you seriously think that
people are just taking advantage of this
to stir up trouble because they're real
troublemakers
you are so diluted and out of touch with
reality that you probably want to one I
like stop following the channel and
being involved in things because I'm
gonna keep on saying stuff like this you
know most of the people that are
involved in these protests are involved
because they've had enough this was a
catalyzing incident
all right when Vanderbeck okay so
there's a great question is there no
screening for police officers right now
I'm from the Netherlands so I don't know
so again unlike European and and most
other police forces all over the world
we do not have a central set of
standards or oversight or rules or
whatever you want we have all of these
different police departments and
sheriff's departments and state troopers
all over the place and each one has its
own set of standards there's actually
even multiple sets of standards that you
could buy into from different policing
organizations I've come in and do
training for you they're not all on the
same page so in one municipality you
could have almost no training and you
know very little screening at all and in
another place you could have screening
that's that's quite extensive it really
depends on what the leadership wants and
what they're willing to pay for and all
these sorts of factors you know all
right the truth I think Marcus Aurelius
would have a lot to say regarding both
the virus and the protesting yeah
probably so Jimmy D shouldn't we ask
ourselves what's wrong with our
ideologies and systems that give birth
to these people it depends on what
people you're talking about Nancy Martin
what is the cumulative factor of the
frustration we feel at the constant
abuse of power and above the law
behaviors of public officials in recent
years okay so that's that's a broader
question it's not just the cops it's
also other public officials including
those who are our representatives and
you know are all of people within the
executive agencies at the federal and
state level and often times here in a
big city like Milwaukee in in terms of
the city officials you know I actually
remember having a phone conversation
with the city engineer when they they
changed the name of our street and
didn't bother to update Google or or
Facebook and and said hey you have a
moral obligation here to make sure that
they're getting accurate information and
they like laughed in my face
and I got a little heated with them so
you could you can encounter this sort of
frustration all the time I think it
again it bears much more heavily on some
people that it does on others and when
it gets to a certain point it's gonna
blow over it or it's gonna blow up
rather I'll give you a prime example so
we had a curfew last night here in
Milwaukee and the the fine for violating
the curfew was a very strange 691
dollars so one of our local sort of
officials judge Derrick Mosley went on
and explained on Facebook that the fine
is actually five hundred dollars then
all the other one hundred ninety one
dollars is Anton's like processing fees
and stuff like that that to me seems
like you know just just ways to screw
people over ways to engage in predatory
practices as a government and there's
lots of it that's part of why Ferguson
was such a powder keg because so many
people in Ferguson were getting hit with
all these crazy fines and extra court
charges and things for for you know
fairly trivial offenses and they would
end up going into debt because of it and
like losing their houses and on top of
that you have the unjust racist policing
right so there's there's a lot of these
frustrations that we need to to deal
with all right
nefarious 401 unfortunately a large part
portion of the American population
doesn't understand that destroying
property is not destroying a person I
think you're right about that and I
think they're very selective about that
too all right
mmm Felice say can you comment on
Candace Owens to paraphrase that if we
truly care about black lives why not
report out the tens of thousands of
murders instead re anti police
propaganda Candace Owens is just a shill
and and you know quite frankly an idiot
or if she's not an idiot she's certainly
playing one so I don't take her
seriously at all we do report on that
you know it gets reported
all the time turn on the local news
sometimes I mean that's all you get for
Milwaukee and Chicago is this murder
happened here this murder happened here
but why can't we report on both you know
this is one of those sort of false
dilemmas that these ideologue like to
put into place well if you if you're
really concerned about this you've got
to talk about this instead no you can
talk about both there's a wide enough
spurt you know span within the internet
that we can actually get to both of
these all right Adam says I think
there's a business incentive to increase
funding for police because the private
companies that provide materials benefit
and police can demand more funding
because of increasing violence that is a
dynamic that does happen yeah I think
that a lot of times
shop owners themselves have to be quite
worried about the police particularly if
they're minorities you know so I don't
know that that's a universal dynamic
Jake lloyd says if you destroy stories
you destroy lots of jobs where people
are economically insecure you destroy
some but you don't necessarily destroy
lots and the stories have you know
depends on who the story is it's a local
mom-and-pop that's a much bigger problem
if it's target they have insurance you
know if it's Walgreens they're covered
and they'll they'll rebuild you know so
I don't really buy that let's go further
down slam RN did you just say the
economy wasn't that good before the
corona virus hit how can you say that
what are you talking about well that's
pretty straightforward and simple the
economy wasn't that good for a lot of
people is what I said so you got to pay
close attention and yeah it wasn't
there's lots of people who are you know
working in the gig economy and don't
have any insurance coverage or I mean if
you're on the ACA like I am you pay a
lot for that there's a lot of people who
lost their their coverage health care
costs have been going way way up wages
have been stagnant for a long time I
mean if you thought the economy was good
for most people before the corona virus
hit
you've been swallowing Fox knew his
propaganda too much and you probably
want to look a little bit more close
and how most other people live so I mean
that this is a no-brainer this one right
all right Kendall can you talk about the
current Hong Kong situation and a
potentially global civil unrest I don't
see this as leading to a global civil
unrest and I see zero connection between
the Hong Kong situation and what's
happening over here I think the two
situations have to do with civil unrest
and you know do involve protests and
policing but that's about as far as you
get so I don't I don't see those
connected with each other all right
let's see what else we've got it just
jumped again and the things so that
tells me there's a lot more comments
scrolling back up to a lot of back and
forth here all right
boy I'm definitely not gonna get to all
these comments and questions that people
have okay so here we go finally back
where I was before a lot of things that
are kind of irrelevant here okay
Watergate 2.0 what kind of police reform
do you think we can enforce on the
police I think that they should be
trailed like if a normal person
committed a crime yeah so the the big
thing that you're asking there what can
we actually enforce and this is where I
think you know we need to be quite clear
that what we want is some pretty
rigorous you know oversight and
enforcement and that you know we're
going to have to fight over and over
again for little bits and pieces and
make it more and more and more and we're
not gonna we're not going to accomplish
this without getting buy-in from at
least some police where they can see
that it's better for them if you know
the bad apples can't spoil the bunch so
one great example is the cameras that a
lot of police have to have now with that
that should be mandatory all the things
that they're doing the camera should be
on all the time if they're on duty and
there shouldn't be any like it takes
five months to get a hold of the camera
footage that should be available to to
everybody that that's one thing we could
push for it would take a long time to
actually get it but it would be it would
be an accomplishment and so you know I
think we can come up with all sorts of
other examples all right do well those
guys says when plunder becomes a way of
life for a group of men in society over
the course of time they create for
themselves a legal system that
authorizes it and a moral code that
glorifies it basquiat that's exactly
what happened in Ferguson with the
predatory governmental fines and stuff
like that
dillan Costco would the government give
equal amount of importance if the
protests were peaceful probably not
that's the thing we don't want to say
that violence is in some way a good
thing in and of itself but one of the
consequences of it is that politicians
do take things seriously when their
there are outbreaks now there's a
suggestion here the United States needs
more colored people in police in cities
okay so there's this issue of
representation but there's also the
issue of what we can call a policeman
tality you know quite often irrespective
of race police can take a non racist
attitudes because of the culture of
their particular department so that
that's a problem
Austin Noonan regarding your comments
about decentralized police force systems
who police's local police in my town an
officer shot and killed a woman driving
away from a house party they
investigated themselves there's the
problem in many cases we don't have any
sort of oversight that goes beyond maybe
they have an Internal Affairs Division
or something like that but if it's small
enough the police do investigate
themselves and along with the local
prosecutor and they usually find that
nothing happened right
this is a big problem sometimes the
Department of Justice will come in but
enhance to take it has to reach like
almost egregious status before the DOJ
gets involved and they usually don't get
compliance from the law enforcement
officers because it's a bad system right
so all right Andrew Egan why are
Americans so undisciplined and protest
that there's looting is it surprising
from inside the US it's actually not
that surprising and it's not as if it's
a uniquely American thing that hooding
takes takes place but yeah it's it it it
usually does happen and it doesn't just
happen by the way for for political
protests it happens when I'm
Americans win sports competitions you
know we or lose them you know people
overturn cars and all that sort of stuff
we do have a big problem with them
nefarious says there's a cultural
problem in America where the large
portion of the population believes
anyone that's in contact with police is
automatically guilty and that it's the
jury's duty to convict that is that is a
nita a problem so slam RN aren't most of
the harsh quarantine orders coming from
Democrat governors why is that well
because Democrat governors actually are
willing to take the problem seriously I
wouldn't call them harsh I'd call them
prudent you know and that's probably all
we need to say about that
Adam McDonald so here's a great point as
well local governments equip their
police better than the public health
care workers so there's two things to
say about that one is that's completely
correct that local governments are much
more invested in policing than they are
public health the other is that this is
reflected in budgets police draw far too
much money from our tax base Public
Health does not we should be changing
our our priorities and you know here in
America that is a change you know we
didn't always spend quite so much on
police as we do now
all right let's let's go on suburban
legend asks what's the Aristotelian view
want social justice in particular the
current situation that's complicated
I've got videos on that you can take a
look at them and read nikka mckay and
ethics book 5 and rhetoric book 1 and
you'll get his take all right dudes what
do you think about gangster culture
influencing young people I think the
hostility towards police makes the
police more hostile and vice-versa I
would say that that was more of an issue
I think when I was younger than it is
today you know like I remember when the
the LA riots were going on and I was in
college and you know hearing the the
after
American fraternity on campus the beta's
playing NWA's you know F the police over
and over and over again and people
getting quite quite worked up about that
but the LA riots took place because of
years and years and years of predatory
policing and you know similar things
there was worries about riots happening
like here in Milwaukee and Chicago and
other places as well why because the
african-american community had been so
oppressed I don't think that the the
gangster culture is like the thing that
we need to target the most I think
that's a useful convenient shot for
white liberals like say the Clintons and
it's always a target for conservatives
but I just don't I don't see I see the
policing is driving that more than the
the gangster rap does alright Jacob says
a new mentality is needed within
policing adopt a habit of exercising
empathy focus on de-escalation instead
of control by force leverage
understanding and reason force prudence
be before justice and I think that's
that that's very good I think that we
need to see a lot more of that we may
also still need to have some you know
hardcore willing to use force behind
that but four should be used a lot less
often than it currently is SN Project
not sure if this has been asked earlier
but what do you suppose is the tendency
for Americans to care more for property
over fellow citizens so I think it's
it's it's selective I think a lot of the
people that are much more concerned
about property over instead of worrying
about people they're concerned about
property unless it were unless it was
their people so if the police were in
their neighborhood and beating people up
and you know pulling them over and
slamming them into the ground and
calling them you know all sorts of slurs
and stuff like that suddenly they would
start caring about people but they don't
see these these other people as people
and so they're much more worried about
property and that's you know part of the
racist attitude
so I think that that's that's part of
what what what's going on there all
right Stacy Washington says in the end
if they were not trustworthy of the
citizenry they themselves with good
reason to fear the police yeah I mean
the police create a lot of the the fear
I don't know that it's really the
master-slave dialectic but you know all
right let's see here
so here's a question from Carol I'm
gonna skip over most of the stuff there
why is the movement called black lives
matter and not all lives matter because
all lives matter is a code word for not
taking black lives matter seriously and
we have a greater problem here with
black lives being treated as expendable
in comparison to two white lives it's
that simple I mean if you need to insist
on all lives matter you're probably one
of the lives that already matters and
you you know you should rethink what
you're doing and consider why other
people need to stress that black lives
matter but because people have been
treated as if they they don't so all
right let's see here yeah okay let's see
scrolling down a bit more a lot of back
and forth about Trump to do see if we
can get anything that's really relevant
ah here we go
not a spectacular review boards have
been established in the past Atlanta for
example however these boards were
dismantled as soon as the next election
yeah they're though there's a big
problem right there's a lot of measures
that are taken basically just to provide
like whoa we're gonna we're gonna
appease the people who have a short
memory span and are willing to say oh
well we took some action and you know
look at what we've accomplished I think
we need to be really cognizant at this
point in time about you know keeping
things in memory and it's a good thing I
think in these protests that so many
people are not just saying George Floyd
but they're bringing up all the other
you know big cases of police using
excessive force and killing
african-american men throughout the you
know the last decade and sometimes even
before that I think it's important to
keep a long memory and like I said
consistent pressure relentlessly applied
and keeping people accountable alright
Earth's Bron Kant rejects revolutionary
violence and violence protests by the
same token as he accepts the possibility
of civilians militia thoughts I think
Kant is not particularly relevant here
so I don't know why you would pick up on
Conte but you know that's that's alright
oh here's a good one by Kent by can you
speak about the philosophy of Truth and
Reconciliation commissions you know as a
way to speak to the truth of in justices
so the Africa has had some success with
it the u.s. seems to deny many aspects
of history yeah so that is that is quite
important and a lot of the anger as I
pointed out earlier is not just because
of injustice being done and you know
things happening over and over and over
again where you can see a pattern of
racist policing it's also about the
denial of it and the cover-ups of it and
the the fact that if it wasn't for cell
phones and recording a lot of these
interactions the police would have just
gotten away with it and the prosecutors
or the investigating police would have
you know as so many have pointed out
here given their their fellow officers
or you know members of law enforcement
of pass I think that's a really
important thing
truth and reconciliation commissions can
in fact accomplish a lot
it requires having like I was saying
buy-in from from the people who who have
engaged in the violence and a
willingness on their part
to say okay I'm gonna I'm going to own
up to the things that have happened and
there are always controversial because
you know they they do involve typically
some sort of amnesty for for the
offenses that have taken place in the
past a lot of people have a problem with
that but we are going to need something
like that in order to move move on past
this as well as oversight as well as you
know retraining of police as well as a
lot of continual activism I think not as
spectacular has got a good point here
this is this is another thing that's
typical of American policing and the
justice system that's not necessarily
typical of other places even if declared
innocent people are stuck with fines
fees lawyers an innocent that's poor
takes just as much damage as the guilty
if you go to jail because the police
decided that they wanted to make an
example of you you can look forward to
losing your business your job your house
all sorts of things and you won't get
anything as recompense unless you know
you can demonstrate to a jury and you
get a lawyer to take your case for
unlawful actions on the part of the
police which is not not you know
feasible and men in many cases so
alright
nefarious says police wear bulletproof
vests because they're in danger of being
shot therefore shouldn't every black man
wear a vest
due to police presence actually that
that makes a lot of sense
matter of fact we can go further and say
that like until racial disparities and
policing get addressed maybe the cop
budget should pay for those those police
those vests right to protect their their
citizens all right let's see
mother says if you look at the markers
for clinical PTSD you'll find the same
markers reveal themselves in the outrage
voiced by people in the lower associate
socio-economic runs that's quite true as
a matter of fact I'll bring up something
that's that's also quite interesting
there I mentioned health disparities
earlier as well as policing and
educational disparities they did these
interesting studies a while back and
they they're looking at why are you no
problems with pregnancies more common
among african-american women than they
are the white women and a lot of that
can be attributed to stress and you know
what living under you know a racist
administration and regime things like
that can can do to a person the thing
that was really the interest in kicker
with this is they also looked at
immigrant women from say the West Indies
or from Africa so people who would be
you know you'd look at them and say AHA
african-american but they're not
actually african-american they're
actually say African and they're their
numbers and when it came to pregnancies
complications still births all that sort
of stuff were similar to that of white
women their children's their daughters
numbers were similar to those of African
American women what does it show you
that you know a lot of the health
disparities that we see are the results
of racism and so you know we can talk
about PTSD we can talk about all sorts
of other things as well let's see if we
can find a good thing to go out on
because we've been talking now for about
an hour and a half and I appreciate the
comments and questions okay so here's
here's a very good one by Proform do I
think citizens have an ethical
obligation to take part in local
politics staying informed and protesting
yes I do think that that we do have an
obligation not just to vote but also to
engage our public officials to be in
formed to not necessarily to protest I
mean maybe in some circumstances it is
particularly complicated by the fact
that you know Co vid is out there and so
we're having spike in numbers because of
that but certainly to communicate and to
take part yes I would say we do have an
ethical obligation I would say that that
ethical obligation is much lower for
those who are disadvantaged and that
there is also a corresponding ethical
obligation on those who are privileged
to act as allies for those who are
disadvantaged this is what solidarity
means and instead you know of trying to
use the system to further their own
positions or to you know set up
boundaries to keep the the you know the
disadvantaged out I would say yeah there
are some ethical obligations like that
so that is a great question to go out on
I thank everybody for for joining me and
those of you whose questions and
comments I couldn't get to sorry I mean
this happens every time but it's
important that we keep these discussions
going and I think what I'm going to say
is I'm going to do I'm gonna do
starting this this coming month maybe an
additional one like this talking about
these these sorts of issues issues of
justice issues of solidarity issues of
society that might be something good to
do alright so thanks everybody and I
will see you in the coming month